welcome back everyone this is the fourth
and final screencast in our series on in
context learning I'm going to talk about
techniques for in context learning and
then suggest some future directions for
you in your own research in this space
as before I'm nervous about giving the
screencast because it's essentially
certain that what turns out to be a
really powerful technique for in context
learning will be discovered in a few
months making some of this seem outdated
in fact one of you might go off and
discover precisely that technique which
will make this screencast scene
incomplete nonetheless I press on I feel
confident that we've learned important
lessons about what works and what
doesn't and those will carry forward no
matter what happens in the field so
let's dive in let's start with the core
concept of a demonstration this is an
idea that stretches back at least to the
gpt2 paper and is indeed incredibly
powerful in terms of Designing effective
in-context Learning Systems let me
illustrate in the context of few shot
open domain question answering which is
our topic for the associated homework
and Bake Off
imagine that we're given the question
who is Bert we're going to prompt our
language model with this question and
hope that it can generate a good answer
by now you probably have an intuition
that it would be effective to retrieve a
context passage to insert into the
prompt to help the model to provide it
some evidence that it can use for
answering the question
the idea behind demonstrations that is
that it might also help to show the
model examples of the kind of behaviors
that we would like to elicit
and so maybe we have a train set of QA
Pairs and we fetch one of those QA Pairs
and insert it into the prompt here I've
put the question who is Kermit and we
would also insert the answer
but this is your first real Choice Point
here so of course you could use the
answer that comes directly from your
trained set of QA Pairs and that could
be effective it will be a gold answer
but counter-intuitively it could be
useful to instead use an answer that you
retrieve from some data store or even
generate using the very language model
that you are prompting right now
and that could be good in terms of maybe
finding demonstrations that are attuned
to what your language model is actually
capable of doing versus just relying on
the gold QA pairs which might be
disconnected from the behavior of your
model and the same kind of lesson
applies to the evidence passages that we
would give for each one of these
demonstrations we could of course if we
have them just use the gold passage from
the train data
but since this is a retrieve passage
down here it might be better in terms of
exemplifying the intended behaviors to
retrieve a passage instead of using a
gold one to better align with the
experience the model actually has for
our Target question again it's
counterintuitive we have this gold
passage why would you use a retrieved
one and it's because it comes closer to
simulating the situation that your model
is actually in
and that's just one lesson for
demonstrations let's think more broadly
about this how might you choose
demonstrations of course you could just
randomly choose them from available data
but perhaps you could do better maybe
you should choose your demonstrations
based on relationships that they have to
your target example for example in
generation you might choose examples
that are retrieved based on similarity
in some sense to the Target input or for
classification you might select
demonstrations to help the model
implicitly determine the target input
type
you might also start to filter your
demonstrations to satisfy specific
criteria for example in generation maybe
we want to be sure that the evidence
passage contains the output string that
would help the model figure out how to
Grapple with the evidence that we
present to it
or in generation you might want the
language model to be able to predict the
correct answer that's an idea that I
alluded to before
in classification maybe a
straightforward thing would be to ensure
that your demonstration set for every
prompt includes every label that's
represented in your data set so that
your model has an example of every
possible behavior and isn't accidentally
limited by the sort of thing that it
sees in the prompt
we could also think about massaging
these demonstrations that we have
available to us maybe we sample them and
then rewrite them with the language
model we could do this to synthesize
across multiple initial demonstrations
maybe that's more efficient and allows
us to include more demonstrations we
could also change the style or
formatting to match the target use the
LM to make the demonstrations more
harmonious with what the language model
expects given the Target or the
capabilities of the language model like
for example if it's really important to
you to generate answers in the style of
a pirate it might be useful to have your
language model actually rewrite the
demonstrations in the style of a pirate
if it has that capability to further
guide it toward the intended Behavior
the fundamental thing that you have to
get used to and it will seem obvious in
retrospect is that four powerful in
context Learning Systems your prompt
might contain substrings that were
generated by a different prompt to that
self-same language model and yes that
could be recursive right even those
substrings might themselves be the
product of multiple calls to your
language model
again it takes some getting used to and
it can be hard to think through how
these systems actually work but the end
result can be something that is very
powerful in terms of kind of aligning
the behaviors of your language model
with the results that you want to see
in that context let me actually linger a
little bit over one of the questions on
the assignment because this is one that
people often find hard to think about
but fundamentally I think it's an
intuitive and Powerful idea this is
about choosing demonstrations
let's start with our usual question who
is Bert
we're going to retrieve some kind of
context passage presumably and then the
question is what to do for
demonstrations
suppose that I find the demonstration
who is Elmo with answer Elmo is a
friendly monster and maybe that's just
from my train set but the train set
doesn't have context passages so what I
decide to do is retrieve a context
Passage
and the context passage that I retrieve
is Elmo is an lstm for contextual
representations
that looks worrisome that context
passage is about a different Elmo than
the one represented in this question
answer pair serving as my demonstration
and you might worry that that is going
to be very confusing for the language
model the evidence is not relevant the
question is could we detect that
automatically I think the answer is yes
the way we do that is by firing off
another instance of the language model
in this case we prompt it with our
demonstration question who is Elmo
we get that same context Passage
and then yes we'll probably insert a
demonstration and for Simplicity right
now let's assume that that demonstration
just comes from some trained data I have
for the context the question and the
answer to keep things simple
so this is a new prompt to our language
model and we see what comes out and the
answer is Elmo is an lstm
and we can observe that that predicted
response to this demonstration does not
match the gold answer in our data set
and we could use that as a signal that
something about this demonstration is
problematic and we throw it out and we
start again
we're back to our question who is Bert
we retrieve our context Passage and we
sample another demonstration instance in
this case the context question and
answer look harmonious
and again we could try to detect that
automatically by firing off another
instance of the language model with our
demonstration question who is Ernie same
retrieved Passage
we sample another demonstration there
and we look at to see what the model
does and in this case the model's
response matches our gold answer and we
decide we can therefore trust this as a
demonstration in the hopes that that
will finally lead to good behavior from
our model
so that's a bit convoluted but I think
the intuition is clear we're using the
language model demonstrations and our
gold data to figure out which
demonstrations are likely to be
effective and which aren't and we're
trying to do that automatically
and yes
for this sum process with this language
model where I just inserted a gold
context question answer pair you can
imagine recursively doing the same thing
of trying to find good demonstrations
for the demonstration selection process
at some point that recursive process
needs to end
let's move to another technique this is
called Chain of Thought and this is also
I think a lasting idea
the intuition behind Chain of Thought is
that for complicated things it might be
simply too much given the prompt to ask
the model to Simply produce the answer
in its initial tokens it's just too much
and so what we do with Chain of Thought
is construct demonstrations that
encourage the model to generate in a
step-by-step fashion exposing its own
reasoning and finally arriving at an
answer
this again shows the power of
demonstrations we illustrate Chain of
Thought with these extensive probably
hand-built prompts and then when the
model goes to do our Target Behavior the
demonstration has led it to walk through
a similar kind of Chain of Thought and
ultimately produce what we hope is the
correct answer assume we didn't lead it
down the Garden Path or it didn't lead
itself down the Garden Path toward the
wrong answer which absolutely can happen
with Chain of Thought
the original Chain of Thought is quite
bespoke we need to carefully construct
these Chain of Thought demonstration
prompts to encourage the model to do
particular things I think there is a
more generic version of this that can be
quite powerful I've called this generic
step-by-step with instructions and here
we are definitely kind of aligning with
the instruct fine tuning that these
models are probably undergoing and
leveraging that in some indirect fashion
here's an illustration I have prompted
Da Vinci 3 with the question is it true
that if a customer doesn't have any
loans then the customer doesn't have any
auto loans it's a kind of complicated
conditional question involving negation
and the model has unfortunately given
the wrong answer no this is not
necessarily true and the continuation is
revealing a customer can have auto loans
without having any other loans which is
kind of the reverse of the conditional
question that I posed it got confused
logically
in generic step by step what we do is
just have a prompt that kind of tells it
something high level about what we want
to do it says logic and Common Sense
reasoning exam explain your reasoning in
detail
and then we give a kind of description
of what the reasoning should look like
and what the prompt will look like using
an informal markup language that
probably the model acquired via some
instruct fine-tuning phase
and then we actually have the prompt
there
and what happens is the model kind of
walks through the logical reasoning and
in this case arrives at the correct
answer and also does an excellent job of
explaining its own reasoning it's the
same model but here it looks like this
generic step-by-step instruction format
LED it to a more productive endpoint
self-consistency is another powerful
method this is from Wang at all 2022 and
it relates very closely to an earlier
model called retrieval augmented
generation this is a kind of complicated
diagram here let me zoom in on what the
important piece is we're going to use
our language model
to sample a bunch of different generated
responses which might go through
different reasoning paths using
something like Chain of Thought
reasoning and ultimately we'll produce
some answers
those answers might vary across the
different generated paths that the model
has taken and what we're going to do is
select the answer that was most often
produced across all of these different
reasoning paths that is technically
speaking a version of marginalizing out
the reasoning paths to arrive at an
answer with the intuition being that the
answer that was arrived at by the most
paths effectively or the most probable
answer given all these paths is likely
to be a trustworthy one and that too has
proved really effective it can get
expensive because you sample a lot of
these different reasoning paths but the
result can make models more
self-consistent
and just by the way in DSP we have a
primitive called DSP dot majority that
actually makes it very easy to do
self-consistency you just set your model
up to generate a lot of different
responses given your prompt template and
then DSP dot majority will figure out
which answer was produced most often
given all of those reasoning paths so a
nice simple primitive that makes
self-consistency essentially a drop in
for any program that you write assuming
you can afford to do all of this
sampling
and for more details on that I would
refer you to Omar's intro notebook which
walks through this in more detail
self ask is another interesting idea so
here is the idea behind self ask is that
we will via demonstrations encourage the
model to break down its reasoning into a
bunch of different questions that it
poses to itself and then seeks to answer
and in that way the idea is that it will
iteratively get to the point where it
can find the answer to the overall
question this is especially powerful for
questions that might be multi-hop that
is might involve multiple different
resources which you can essentially
think of as being broken down into
multiple sub questions that need to be
resolved in order to get an answer to
the final question
so that's self-ask and it has an
intriguing property for us as retrieval
oriented researchers self-ass can be
combined with retrieval for answering
the intermediate questions so instead of
trusting the model generations for those
intermediate questions you'd look to
something like a search engine like in
the paper they use Google to answer
those questions the answers get inserted
into the prompt and the model continues
so that's self-ask or maybe self-ask and
Google answer
other very powerful general idea that
I'm sure will survive no matter what
people discover about in context
learning is that it can be useful to
iteratively rewrite parts of your prompt
you could be rewriting demonstrations or
the context passages that they contain
or the questions or the answers I've
given some code here that shows how this
plays out in the context of multi-hop
search where we're essentially Gathering
Together evidence passages for a bunch
of different sources synthesizing them
into the into one and then using those
as evidence for answering a complicated
question but the idea is very general
especially given a limited prompt window
or a very complicated syst situation in
terms of information it might be helpful
to iteratively have your language model
rewrite parts of its own prompt and then
prompt the model with those Rewritten
chunks as a way of synthesizing
information and getting better results
very powerful idea
in the context of all of this I thought
I would just call out some results from
the DSP paper
so in the DSP paper we evaluate across a
bunch of different knowledge intensive
tasks most of them oriented toward
question answering answering or
information seeking dialogue
the high level takeaway here is that we
can write DSP programs that are
Breakaway winners in these competitions
that is the final row of this table here
you can see us winning across the board
we are often winning by very large
margins and the largest margins are
coming from the most underexplored data
sets like music you and pop QA
the lesson here is first of all that DSP
is amazing and Omar and the team did an
amazing job
but I think the deeper lesson is that it
is very early days for these techniques
the only time you see these kind of
breakaway results for modeling is when
something new has happened and people
are just figuring out what to do next
and we kind of caught that wave I expect
the Gap to close as people discover more
powerful in context learning techniques
and I would just encourage you to think
about DSP as a tool for creating prompts
that are truly full-on AI systems we
want to bring the software engineering
to prompt engineering and really think
of this as a first class way of
Designing AI systems and if we move into
that mental model I think we're going to
see more and more Breakaway results and
we will indeed realize the vision of
having in-context Learning Systems
surpass the fine-tuned systems that were
self that were supervised in the
classical mode
but it's going to take some creativity
and there's lots of space in which to be
creative right now
that's a good opportunity for me to
queue up this final part of these
screencasts some suggested methods for
you as you think about working in the
space first as a working habit create
Devon test sets for yourself based on
the task you want to solve aiming for a
format that can work with a lot of
different prompts and do this first so
that as you explore you have a fixed
Target that you're trying to achieve
that will help you get better results
and be more scientifically rigorous
learn what you can about your target
model
about how it was trained and so forth
paying particular attention to whether
it was tuned for specific instruction
formats I think we have already seen
that the extent to which you can align
with its instruct fine tuning data you
will get better results often we don't
know what that data set was like but we
can Discover it in a kind of heuristic
fashion at least in part
think of prompt writing as AI system
design that's what I said before try to
write systematic generalizable code for
for handling the entire workflow from
Reading data to extracting responses and
analyzing the results that is a kind of
guiding philosophical idea behind DSP
but even Beyond this DSP I think this is
an important methodological note we
shouldn't be pecking out prompts and
designing systems in that very ad hoc
way we should be thinking about this as
the new mode in which we program AI
systems and take it as seriously as we
can
and finally for the current and perhaps
brief moment prompt designs involving
multiple pre-trained components and
tools seem to be underexplored relative
to their potential value for this unit
we are exploring how a retrieval model
and a language model can work in concert
to do powerful things but we could
obviously bring in other pre-trained
components and maybe even other just
core computational capabilities like
calculators weather apis you name it
thinking about how to design prompts
that take advantage of all of those
different tools is a wonderful new
Avenue we're starting to see exploration
in this space and it is sure to pay off
in one form or another so maybe go forth
and see what kind of value you can
extract out of this new mode of tooling
around prompting